managed directing the mandalorian you
make make sure it's but like this is
like a Star Wars show you know what the
the God's honest truth is that I had I
had incredible support from Dave Filoni
and Jon Favreau and and the the process
Minoo the prep process and the shooting
and posts and all of that it was so
incredibly collaborative and fun and
grounded and and so I just it was just
it was I wanted to just one follow-up
yeah what can you tease about your
episode if anything yes and can you talk
a little bit about the insane technology
they use yes
okay so um I literally don't even think
I can tease anything about this episode
I don't think I can say which episode
it's yeah no I'm I'm totally on lockdown
but what I can say about the technology
it's it's really Jon Favreau of course
is is known for pushing emerging
technology forward and what he did with
with Jungle Book what he's doing now
with Lion King I mean this is really
extraordinary sort of what what is
possible because of because of these
projects and because of the way I mean
there were so many times when when I
would be like oh it's okay Jon we can
just we can just do it that way he's
like I just want to see if it's possible
like we just need to see if it's
possible and I'm like okay and then it's
tested and way more times you know you
find out oh wow it is possible and it's
better you know and and so um so yeah so
that was really exciting there's
specifically something that we shot in
called that we called the volume and and
basically you you step into it and you
are you the naked eye you can't tell
that you are
surrounded by basically LED screens and
you feel like wherever you know the
story is taking place it's almost like a
this is the this is the wrong term to
use especially for this for this project
but it's almost like a holodeck